hi I'm Denise I'm a tattoo artist and
I'm Sadie I'm a painter
and today we are going head-to-head to
paint someone's arm based on a theme for
battling I'm scared I decided I wanted
to be tattooer
when I was 13 years old by the time I
turned 18 I was able to pursue my first
apprenticeship and then I came to Los
Angeles I pursued a second one and I
have been working for the last eight
years consistently so I've been painting
off and on for about ten years this year
have actually finally launched like my
own Etsy shop so I'm now professionally
selling my artwork but my background is
in like abstract oil painting so I'm
excited to see what I can do with body
paint it's magic oh okay I'm like I'm
thinking like sparkles and just I'm
gonna go full on abstract cuz that's
really all I know and that's my comfort
zone so no fine lines and details for me
yeah weird
I'm the arms yeah here are my arms I put
all my best ones today those are the
paper grab you grabbed me I'm gonna grab
you time your canvas this is gonna be
weird this feels so good does it
I'm gonna ask what is your game plan
right now I'm excited I'm gonna do some
like just cool colors gonna be like
abstract and I'm gonna add some sparkles
on the top and then it's just gonna be
like a magic wand right there so it
seems like all this magic coming out of
the magic wand that's what I'm gonna do
and I'm excited and what are you doing
I'm sorry I might want to curse he'll
believe it I've always wanted to be
bleep good what dreams come true does it
make you nervous and I'm right here in
your face watching like I'm like kind of
shaking but I just need to like relax
and let get used to this
[Music]
okay I remember when I was it was like
when I was in art class it was an oil
painting class and we were told not to
like ever eat around oil paints because
they're highly toxic I know this but I
always eat around like when I paint like
you have to have snacks but then I get
paint everywhere and then I'm like I'm
pretty sure I just ate poisons like a
oil paint for sure I feel like that
happens a drink
brush water a lot I know it's bad no I
know you know how many times I'm afraid
I'm gonna like drink turpentine like the
thing that you clean your oil with it's
crazy
[Music]
I'm doing great I have one small pain in
my wrist but otherwise I'm fine which
we're here well it's just I'd want to
stay still because you can't go this way
is that what the problem is your friend
yeah you know I don't think I really
like body painting I don't like the way
that it is not doing what I want it to
[Music]
there's glitter II guess you get a
dragon you've been pretty good yeah see
there's so many fun things happening
over there on that side oh not good done
I had a great time the paint that's
helped was a bit challenging so we have
a magic wand on my left arm here I like
it a lot the colors blend very
beautifully I think it's a very literal
interpretation which isn't bad it's just
literal and I like it it's what I would
think of when I think of magic it's like
I feel like I finally got it down at the
end that I wished that now I could go
back and do the background because it
would have been a lot prettier but I'm
proud of it I mean didn't know what the
hell I was doing with the stuff so well
it's rad it's still good my other room
I've really mostly only have been able
to see this corner of oh wow it is
really sparkly can you see it
I can also now see it Wow she's wearing
a thick ring oh yeah
that's incredible I like I appreciate
her literal take on magic and this is
blowing me away in a different way
yeah every wanted to do this for so long
listen oh they're incredible the
challenge is officially complete I have
done my assessment of both arms and it
has been decided that the niece is the
winner
well deserved well it is fair
hands down great job thank you guys I
really appreciate it so much I had such
a good time fighting with you guys today
[Music]